let's let's let's yeah look at this the
turret of this is this really amazing oh
NYC authorities weld Brooklyn playground
shut one day after massive black trans
live matter protest
I appreciate the article National Review
but boy I gotta say you missed it it's a
good job it's a good job I'm I trying to
drag drag you guys but they're literally
protesting right now okay this is from
today
4:26 p.m. monday is the 19th consecutive
day of protests in NYC wow you can see
all the people out and about standing
shoulder to shoulder doing the thing but
it's okay they're wearing masks right
that's the thing I guess right sure now
here's what we got here's what here's
what the Jewish community has to do they
have to actually use bolt cutters to pry
open the gates because the city came and
welded it shut yeah so messed up his
creepy stuff man I'm sorry dude I'm
getting more and more creeped out every
day you know why Chelsea Handler she
posts a video of Farrakhan I don't know
if you guys have ever listened to
Farrakhan this dude really hates the
Jews Wow and he's got a ton of support
among high-profile black lives matter
activists Chelsea Handler post this
video it's on our Instagram right now
you can go look at it read her comments
and I'm telling you man these people are
are in there losing it it's funny
because I really hate comparing
everything to to Nazi Germany well it's
but it's pretty easy to do so nowadays
and they say the same thing about the
right they're like oh no Trump and it's
like what does Trump doing his Supreme
Court nominee gorsek just wrote the the
the opinion in favor of LGBTQ rights in
the in the ruling today
Hitler asked yes just like Hitler haha
but you look at what Chelsea hands are
posted and this freaks me out
Farrakhan video where a woman opens by
straight-up saying you've given up and
you're basically a bigot who thinks we
need to be separated and he goes yup
Chelsea Handler posts that like wow
enlightening and then you look at the
comments and people are like I can't
believe you would post this and she goes
no you don't understand the one the
craziest one I think is where someone
said if you found a video of like an
early Hitler do you think that would be
good to post if he made his points and
she said the difference is that Hitler
you know
millions of Jews and Farrakhan is just
an anti-semite and it's like but that's
the same thing as finding a young Hitler
exactly for he killed everybody right
like what's the difference or then it's
a young but they're like you found a
video of Hitler or something okay but
the point is like if if so if someone is
espousing Nazi rhetoric because they
didn't literally lead the charge you
think that's okay Chelsea Handler yeah
what no I'll tell you what I think man I
think these people are overt
anti-semites and the reason why I draw a
parallel with Nazi Germany is simply
because I don't if you've ever seen that
photo where all the dudes all the people
are doing the salute and there's one guy
like this yeah I've seen it I'm like I
wonder what that guy was thinking yeah I
wonder what he's thinking is everyone
around him just blindly was like oh you
know like here we go mm-hmm and then I
talk to my friends and boy do they try
everything in their power to justify the
overt anti-semitism that's come out of
these people these groups I don't
understand that they do that this is
it's like they're trying to make sure
racism stays alive like no no we got to
keep racism
I mean it's worse than that yeah it
hasn't even in a hundred years serious
since World War two and now you've got
so you know you know how happen with the
women's March no you know the women's
March is it was sure five million people
protests it was the biggest protest in
that in in and yeah and the [ __ ] heads
and in Washington DC the protest was so
large that the whole protest march
wrapped around and touched itself it was
one ring it wasn't even a March anymore
they were supposed to march around this
area it just connected uh-huh so you
could like what was wow it's massive so
so if they were playing snake they lost
yeah
the organizers had to quit because they
were it was discovered that they were
overt anti-semites who believed crazy
conspiracy theories about the Jews Wow
they were saying stuff like they were
saying crazy stuff about the slave trade
and apparently like some of the some of
the other early organizers who was one
woman who was Jewish was like getting
freaked out like this stuff's not real
this is like white supremacist like
insane and they told her shut up
Wow and then it wasn't until how long
did it take like six seven months or
something it took quite a while quite a
while yeah it was an expose from a
Jewish magazine that was like do you
realize who you're propping up yeah and
then you like
one of these women like that they're all
associated with like Ocasio cortez and
the progressive left okay so here we
here we have this is this is the this is
the man it's such a weird thing to me
black lives matter is an identity in
movement okay
on the surface I'm not saying it's bad I
dislike it okay it's basically like
identity as a pretext for policy
political action protests etc you
sprinkle in the fact that you've got
Chelsea Handler now actively promoting
Farrakhan what Farrakhan has said in
what he believes and I'm like so you
have an anti-semitic identitarian group
that really does overlap with the Nazis
no I know white supremacy right but men
to see what Bill de Blasio has been
doing over the past several months what
was it in April he went to a funeral
service arrested people yeah me and then
and then in May threatened threatening
him all again now it's not even like I
don't look man I don't I don't I don't
know if somebody wants to explain to me
what's going on with this guy but what
did he do he specifically targets the
Jewish community he by welding their
Park shot like let me show you what they
did let's play this clip right here so
here's what looks like as them opening
up yeah let me make it a buys yeah they
have to actually get bolt cutters and
they make it happen man yeah I do now
why does this keep happening to the
Jewish community here let me tell you
something else man that's freaking me
out do you know about the the the the
random attacks on Jews in New York
that's been going on for a long time no
how long has it's been going on for a
year here there's videos where just like
people in in in Brooklyn will run up and
just start beating on Hasidic Jews Wow
yep and that's everywhere so they form
something called you know the group is
called they form they look at that yeah
yeah that there's a group of they have
patrol cars that look like NYPD okay and
it's got like a emblem on it and they
call it I don't the name is cuz I'm not
super familiar Jewish Defense League no
no no no judge with an SH I think the
shomron cha murim unarmed acidic patrols
yep Hasidic patrols because of how bad
the anti Simon
has been getting in New York and look
man a lot of these videos the attacks
are from young black men doing it yep
so I'm not saying this is a point of
like I really really doubt the entirety
of the black community is okay with us
about it's it's I'm I'm saying I think
it's like a rare sect of people that are
infiltrating that are overtly
anti-semitic but their views are getting
like to the higher level you know dude
it's like they're they're infiltrating
and appropriating all of these different
movements and making it like like
subverting it all and making it their
fight like by the way this is the root
of it all is this what we've you know
we're claiming you know I I think I
think that the white supremacist and
like neo-nazi types are just sitting
back there just sitting back and
watching yeah they I I don't know for
sure I don't know what they're doing but
they kind of disappeared and all of a
sudden we have all these stories popping
up of like these specific things it's
it's very strange to me I was talking to
my friend earlier today and I said look
at this video from Chelsea Handler and
they're like well I mean that video was
really old and I was like they just
posted it but it's a video from the 90s
what they do just post a new one and
many and they want you to see it now
and read the words listen to the words
and what's going on in the UK with
Winston Churchill yeah so a bunch of
protesters are threatening to tear down
Winston Churchill literally the guy who
killed Hitler all right yeah and so they
had to box it up to protect it because
Churchill's racist they said I was
talking to a friend and I said can you
believe they want to tear down Churchill
now isn't it weird that all these things
keep happening Bill DeBlasio targets the
Jewish community over and over and over
again
Chelsea Handler promoting Farrakhan the
organizers of the women's March
promoting Farrakhan and the things he
said doesn't strike you as odd now they
want to tear down Winston Churchill
maybe maybe it's confirmation bias
either way these things shouldn't be
allowed just like that we shouldn't
stand for this
yeah but yeah I think so I think this is
just another supremacist group so I
think the Nazis are obviously white
supremacy this is something that Terry
Crews was talking about when he was
tweeting earlier he was like being a
black supremacist is not a good answer
to white supremacy you need no
supremacists we actually need equality
so I write I just think it's more
supremacy I think
just it's the flip side of the coin
they're targeting the same people and
for some reason they all hate Jewish
people I'm not sure that's really so you
want to know what my friend said to me
when I said like Churchill literally
killed Hitler like this guy is a world
war ii hero he didn't actually killed
kill hitler in in public trigger no but
it was the UK leading the charge with
the aid of united states who stormed the
beaches of normandy like the UK was the
last bastion of europe yeah i know i
know i know look people gonna argue it
was stalin who killed Hitler or whatever
it was the Communists didn't kill
himself yeah so but so the point I'm
making is not that wins a churchill
literally walked in and went Hitler mild
boy I just had to go
you got a poke fun at you when I can but
that's literally what she said to me
right should know Hitler actually killed
himself I'm like yeah I know but he was
surrounded by Allied forces yeah but
well yeah Churchill didn't do it and I'm
like no no no the UK and the u.s.
stormed the beaches of Normandy so I
yeah I know we can give the US the moat
we saved them for sure yeah but
Churchill was one of the leaders who led
the charge to do this okay sure I'm
being a little I guess hyperbolic and
saying he did it but you know at the
point I'm trying to make it yeah he was
one of the leaders on the side that
stopped the Nazis yeah
and now it's no you know like the
desperate attempt to defend what is
clearly in front of our eyes it's
freaking me out man or how they're
they're calling to take down the
emancipation stage statute what was that
all about Abraham Lincoln yeah oh they
vandalized that nuke a Mansa pating
right exactly yeah whose but who said
that I didn't there's there's like a
tweets an online petition to like take
it down you know what man that's the
president that that emancipated slaves
like Churchill
why would I would I would normally say
it must be a troll but in the UK I don't
know no no listen in the UK they
vandalized the statue of Lincoln mm-hmm
and in Portland they tore down a statue
of Thomas Jefferson they tore down a
statue of Jefferson they threw up
surround and hold it down and there what
slave owner on it it's like yeah man if
you go back in time every single person
who ever lived was bad yeah did you know
that certain indigenous people would
literally sacrifice virgins yep we got
it we got to cancel them gotta cancel
them they murdered innocent people they
were
abuses misogyny oh man no we get it man
we want it we want to remember you know
what I always tell people you gotta
remember the good and get rid of get rid
of the bad so in order to build up a
Great Society we say hey look at this
really great things that work let's take
these things look there's really bad
things that were like really awful let's
get rid of those things like we used to
duel I was reading about it
I was reading about dueling today he had
we talked about doing yeah
first it was swords rapiers yeah then
they got pistols so I was reading about
it apparently it wasn't really to the
death no it was just the act of dueling
restored your honor that you weren't
willing to back down and when it came to
pistols you know you people wouldn't
often get hit yeah and with swords it
would they were disarmed and win it back
AHA but the other guy who lost was still
like I'd stood for my honor I defended
myself
that kind of makes sense how can we do
that nowadays what non-lethal way can we
we bring that around they got I don't
know able to restore your honor
yeah well it's been happening online
duel no have no no no have you seen the
boxing matches between like these ISA
labs no no what's going on Ted Cruz and
Ron Perlman
yeah let's wrestle oh that's yeah
basically that's I'm saying doing all
the time
I honestly on my tweets I say what
should we talk about and some of those
talk about this and then they'll be like
whoa you're so wrong and then I watch
the duels happen box it out yeah I'm
like wow this is and 90% of the time
someone ended up getting blocked you
know what maybe this is why everything's
falling apart
because we got rid of dueling I think
you're right yeah think about it you get
two people on Twitter who are arguing
each other yeah you say hey hey stop
mm-hmm no more tweeting it outside we're
gonna bring you into the ring we're
gonna give you gloves or did I have a
ref ref on standby so nobody gets
critically injured or anything he's
gonna box it up
I mean box it up you know why that
wouldn't really work though I mean
that's a physical thing remember the
video abroad boy knocked out the
anti-fog eye that's exactly why they
would never win right it's like that
video man where the probably winds up
and then boom and the guy just goes
rigid oh man these people man they don't
have a fight thanks for checking out
this clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on
toons and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you